as of 2019 it was estimated that over
463 million people have diabetes
worldwide and here to talk about that
and how to properly treat it as shattery
bonds from P3 Health Partners of Nevada
the sponsors of the Silicon segment
welcome it's so good to have you here
thank you it's very common a lot of
people have diabetes can you tell us
exactly what diabetes is yeah diabetes
is a lifelong disease it affects the way
that your body's able to use insulin or
the way that you produce insulin and so
it creates a problem with how we use
sugar and convert energy so we've heard
of Type 1 Diabetes Type 2 diabetes can
you tell us what the difference is
between the two type 1 diabetes is
usually diagnosed early in life it's
autoimmune where your body is attacking
its own cells you don't produce insulin
we have to give you insulin injections
type 2 diabetes is more common you see
that diagnosed in your adulthood usually
and usually that one is where you're not
producing enough insulin or your cells
are resistant to the insulin you're
producing so we can use medication to
help with that it sounds like you guys
have really come a long way in in the
treatment of diabetes do you feel like
you're seeing that there are lots of new
treatment options and combinations and
diabetes has been so much easier to
control with the new technology that's
coming out let's talk about our senior
population and how can they keep
diabetes under control so diabetes is
something that is responsive to your
lifestyle so one thing you can do to
help prevent diabetes is healthy
lifestyle keep moving exercise however
if you have diabetes all of those things
still apply we just have to do a few
extra things we screen for organ damage
that diabetes causes you want to stay up
to date on screenings like your eye exam
Labs work and things like that the other
thing you want to do is monitor your
blood sugar at home make sure you take
your medications as prescribed arrived
and understand what they're what you're
taking them for and the best thing
someone that has diabetes can do is to
understand what the food does to them so
understanding what you eat and what that
in turn does for your body it really
does just it like flips a switch if
people want to get medical assistance
with whether it's diabetes or something
else tell us a little bit about P3
Health Partners Nevada sure P3 Health
Partners we're a medical group we're
clinician LED and we're patient centered
and so there are 11 medical groups here
in the southern Nevada and we have 400
Affiliates around as well and so we're
available
so many insurance plans it's great
you're so knowledgeable not just about
this but we're talking off the air about
other things and and it's so great that
all the people that work at P3 are as
knowledgeable as you thank you so much
for taking your time and and informing
us about diabetes we really appreciate
it thank you thank you to P3 Health
Partners Nevada they sponsored this
segment you can call them get
information at
702-333-4700 or visit
p3mg.org for more information we will be
right back